ご視聴ありがとうございました
ラムネ一本お願いできる?
ラムネいっちょー!
うまい!暑いときはこれに限りますわね
まだ暖房がいる季節だっつーのに、変なやつだな
ぺーぽん
おい兄ちゃん
はい
場が荒れるだろうが
第一だから自廃一徳にお高瀬をあげに来るんじゃねえ
何言うてんねんおっさん
さては国志無双狙いやったな
うーん、どれ切ろうかなー。
おい、姉ちゃん。
はい。
積もったら3秒で切れ。それ以上かかるのは考えじゃねえ。迷いってもんだ。
だって、本当にわかんないんだもん。
口やかましいな。何なんだこの人。
リーチや!
おーし、いいリーチだ。
いつ狙いのいいシャンテン。どっちでもいいから引けー。
えぇ?
引いた!
アンパイの射撃って、ケンジンの現物リーチ!
なんだ、今男のパイが揺れたような?
ロンダ、三眼光、チュン、フンロック!
スクワー
ウォシ!ピンフテンパッター!
うぉおー!続いて確定3色テンパッター!
ここはアキナちゃんとケンジンの援護射撃を期待して
ウリャー!リーチだ!
本家、一万八千
あれは伝説のカゲロウウチ
カゲロウウチ
カゲロウウチとは昭和十年代に活躍したジャンシー
藤枝バイマンが最も得意とした
握り込みの一種である
体内に取り入れた大量の炭酸ガスを熱に変換し
放出することによって周囲の空気を影の斧ごとく屈折させ
他のメンツに悟られないようにパイをすり替えるという
まさに幻の秘なのだ
その技をやすやすと使いこなすなんて一体何者
あ、あなたは伝説の裏プロ、桜田門外
え、幻のジャンキーと言われ、昔から恐れられたあの
うん、少しは知ってるようだな
ま、明日の大会にも顔を出してやるからよ
賞金の封筒に門外様と書いて用意しとくんだな
ごめん、そばっせ
あんな人まで出てくるんじゃ一般のお客さんがしらけちゃうわね
ママさん大会って
実はね明日やるのよ
一番完敗争奪大麻雀大会
優勝賞金はなんと100万円
100万円
わあすごい人ね
さあみなさんそれぞれのゼッケンの指定の宅へお座りください
予選は2回
決勝進出はポータルでトップから4名のみです
この中に昨日の桜の門外がいるのか
せめて予選で当たらないといいけど
おまえお二人とも決勝で会いましょう
頑張ってね
ほなな
じゃあね豊臣くん頑張ってね
は、は、はい、えっと、僕の宅…
おい、トヨトビ、こっちじゃ、こっち!
あはっ、師匠!
神茶は師匠、トイメンは平凡な学生風。
ぐぅ、なんとか勝てそうと…
ここでしたかしら?
さ、桜の門外!
あら、またお会いしましたわね。よろしくお願いしまーす。
つ、違う。
え?
うわー!
どうしよう!
おー!
こ、こ、ハイパイは、
中連冒頭のキュメマチ先輩!
変だ、
遠い日極のハイパイから、
こんなヒントが来るなんて!
どうした?
親が切らなきゃ始まらないぜ。
そうか、罠だ!
くそー、門外がいきなり仕掛けてきやがった。
おそらく、このすすを切れば、
あ、ダブリー!
レンホー。あ、ほんの挨拶代わりだ。受け取ってくんな。
とかなんとか言って当たるに決まってる。
じゃあ、ウーアン斬りのスーソタンキで勝負か?
ダブリー!
やはり出たな。
そいつだ!
やっぱりそれぐらい読んでるに違いない。
じゃあ、一旦イーシャンテンに戻して、イーワンかキューワンを2枚落とし、ツーソーにくっつきのピンク5つ狙いか!
甘いな、ロン・ツーアンコ!
ああ、ダメだダメだ!相手は20年間無敗の裏プロ!裏の裏場で見切って、イーキューワンの短期も十分ありうる!
一体何を切ればいいんだ?
見えた!ここはやはりこれしかない!
ど、どうだ、意表をついた戦法だぜ
甘く見るなよ、桜田さんよ
こんな子供騙しの罠にはまるような僕じゃないぜ
もう何度も地獄を見てんのよ
来たー!
敵だ!
完璧な仕上げだ
かっかっかっかっかっかっ
通らばオラも追っかけっぺ
親に向かってドラサバで突っ張りやがって怪我するぜ
トヨタビピーチ
一発ウラドラ乗ってロック4
素直にスーソー切っとくべきじゃったな
甘いですよ師匠
桜田さんの山から取ってこのハイパイ
どう考えたって
小僧俺が積み込んだとでも
いや別に
すべくべ抜かす前にこれ見てものを言え
手の内バラバラ
何驚いてんだ
いくら俺でもこの宅で積み込めができるわけがねえだろ
しまった
この宅は全自動宅だったんだ
タイヤを飲み関数は待ち
メンタンピン3色イーペーコー
ハネマン転売
ラン1300
ん?
ってか
おい小僧その上がりはなんだ
何って?
それが麻雀打ちの上がりかと聞いてんだ
いいか これが次のお前さんのツモ
ツモってもご当だ わざわざ見逃す必要はないしょ
そうじゃねえ 次のツモはこれよ
トンガなんか?
まあ 次のツモを見な
次のツモか 次の 次の 次の 次の 次の 次の 次の 次の 次の
見ろ!
三色天牌だろ!
ここはワンパイですが?
そんなことはどうでもいい!
麻雀ってのはな、役満上がれるときは役満。
万眼上がれるときは万眼をきっちり上がんなきゃいかんのよ。
この手を三色まで伸ばさず、五順目タンヤゴで蹴るお前には、勝利の女神は微笑まねえ。
逆に振った俺は海が取れたってわけよ
このふてぶてしさに飲まれたら負けだ
ここは小刻みに上がりをキープして
リーチ!
小僧、歳はいくつだ?
21ですが
だったらまだやり直しがきく
ここでその数相が出るようなら
麻雀やめて国へ帰った方がいい
な、なに?
どれどれ?
この手から切り出しなのか
な、なにすんですか!あんたこれチョンボやん!
心配すんな!当たってんだよ、その数相。悪いがな
ズカーン!
ズワッコ!
腹そろひれ
トヨタミ、それはドラじゃ!
ファンタス三色ドラドラ
20年間無敗を誇る裏プロ
桜田門外 恐るべし
お疲れ様でした
1回戦終わって6万点ダウントストップ!
次流しても決勝進出はいただきや!
さーて、アキナハンたちの戦況はと?
な、なんや?あの人だかりは!
一体何事ですの?
いやー、ここまだトン4局になるんすけどね。
さっきからずーっとあの子が連チャンして…
あ、ま、まさか!
あーーー!
相撲!告示武装!
えっと、4万8千点の十二本葉は、5万1千6百点だから、1万7千2百点持って、全員集合!
ああ、もういいよ!
さすが、アキナハン!これなら、目つぶってでも決勝いけますぜ!
あれ?トヨタミ君は?
え?マイナス20万点?
最下位や!
いやー!
-豊臣くん!-どないした?
桜田門外よ!
桜田門外?
あっちゃん、やっぱり来てたのね。
奴を倒さん限り、やっぱ優勝は難しそうでんな。
無駄だ無駄だ。諦めてとっとと帰んな。
なんやて?
この流れになったら次も俺の断トツだ。
誰にも止められねえよ。
20年間、俺を止めた奴はいなかった。
ほんならその記録、ワイが止めたるワイ!
小僧が生きがるのは勝手だが、怪我をしないようにせいぜい気をつけな。
これより二回戦を行います!
豊臣くん、いつまでもピヨピヨ言ってる場合じゃないわよ。悔しくないの?
ずかん。
戦いはまだ終わってないわ。今負けた分は二回戦で取り戻せばいいじゃない!
所詮チャンソーのバイトで行きまいていた程度の僕なんかが
叶う相手じゃなかったんだ
20年間無敗の裏プロなんて
諦めちゃダメよ
最後の最後まで精一杯やってみなくちゃ
もういいんだ
僕のことは本当にだ
君は決勝へ進んでくれ
豊波くんのバカ
相手が裏プロだろうが幻のジャンキーだろうが
同じ人間であることに変わりはないじゃない
同じ人間?
桜田さんの方がちょっと先に生まれていただけの話よ。
あなたにはその年輪の差を補って余りある。
えっと、余りある。
とにかく頑張ればなんとかなるわよ。ね、ね、ね。
今、僕の調子思いつかなかったでしょ。
つべこべ言わずにさすかと行きなさい。
お願いしまーす
なんだ、またお前か
えええええええ!
2回連続で問題と同じタッグ!
相手がウラプロだろうが、幻のジャンキーだろうが
同じ人間であることに変わりはないじゃない!
そ、そうだ、ウラプロだなんだといったところで
所詮は人の子、運や月までは変えられやしないはずだ!
ロン!
三色ドライチ
ツン!
ノンセンニセン
ロン!
レンホンサンアンコドラサン!
頼む!ペンタンピンドラドラ!
スーパーズワー!
きゃ!豊臣くん!
やっぱり奴は人間じゃなかった。
豊臣くん!しっかりして!
ケンジンくん!
きゃ!師匠!
うちのタグにもプロが!めちゃ強い奴が!
天は我を見放した!
3人とも
久しぶりだね 秋名くん
あなたは東大出身の麻雀師 井出さん
私のことも忘れてもらっちゃ困るな
史上プロの金子さん
何考えてんねん この人ら
プロがこんな店にまで来て 優勝狙うか 普通
よもスレじゃって ポワ
ジャンプロも生活が厳しいのだ
そらしゅうございますわね
桜田門外
さあ決勝進出の予選上位4名が決定しました
この4名です
果たして優勝賞金100万円は誰の手に
やっと東大出身の僕の実力が発揮できるメンツが揃ったようですね
予選の連中はどれも歯応えがなくてね
昔の五流の裏プロの足元にも及ばねえ貴様らごときが
一流の裏プロである俺にかなうはずがねえ
とっとと帰ってそこら辺のジャングルでも相手にしてな
何?
言わせておけば
私戦う志半ばにして散っていった豊臣くんたちのためにも
大丈夫ですやのか秋名さん
いくら驚異的なツキを持つ秋名ちゃんといえども
黒ジャンシー三人に囲まれてはの
秋名ちゃん
秋名は前線した
秋名の点数はオーラスでマイナス一万点
そして
さあいよいよオーラスです
さくらだもんがい ここまで4000点のトップ!
ポン!
こっちは勝負手なんだ
なんなんかで蹴られてたまるか
ポン!
よーし
今回は三巡目早くも天敗。高めパー1で、白、純、トイトイ、三アンコ、ハネマンだ!
このままでは、タイヤをのみだ。
まだ四巡目、いい三点に戻して、もっといい形に受けよう!
おっと、金子はん!天敗取らずにローピン切りよった!
おっと迷っているのか、プリティアキナス!
どうせならスーアンかローアンを出せ
なければシャータンキで少数詞100万だ
それ切ったら危ない
これでイデプロは40名で少数詞一社待ちってばいやで
スーアンを泣けばチーアンで俺にぶち込みだったのか
運のいい奴め
よし
カン!
ほう、カンドラを積もったか。
ここは俺の流れだ。一気に決めてやる。
ゲー!白磁の翻弄、トイトイ、三顎、ドラドラ。
ハネマンを倍満に変更だ!
来た!
リーチ!
こっちもきついわ。
カネコプロ、五巡目で、低めでハネマン、高めウーピンで、メンタンピン三色ドラサン!
おやばいリーチや!
あー、どうしよう…
よし、こっち!通してー!
同巡アキナ!可愛い追っかけです!
ち、地位はまずったか…
それじゃ!
おーっと!同巡イデプロ!
オーソーブに出たー!
舐めやがって!
こんな Alright
端
カネコプロのドラが増えよっと
これで薬品振込にでもおrul Hasta el precio o Preis
これがジャンキの魔ジャンよ It's the magic of magic
白昼の本をといとい!今夜寒夜かけられ!白焼 Ally! Spring! When I wake up
称賛本朗、といとい、三額を三貫通、三倍満に変更だ!
だせぇ、小数子!
だせぇ、親倍満!
だせぇ、三倍満!
アキラちゃん!
アキラはぁん!
やだぁ、おじさんたちの顔怖い!
リーズもちいといドラハチ
僕たちの街を
全部
統一にしとる
ビンゴカーター
ジャストミート!早見明菜さんの優勝!
ハッピーダッシュアップ!
やったー!
はーい!
こうして、幻のジャンキー桜田門外は去っていった。
20年間無敗を誇っていた彼の勝負運を狂わせたのは、一体何だったのか。
俺は、女からは当たらない主義なのさ。
ああ、男はその美学によって生きる
トヨタミ君
何?アキナちゃん
トヨタミ君、さよなら
アキナちゃん
次回スーパーズガン最終回
つかんこよとわにパート1パート2
きっと見てね
ねむっちゃや
ご視聴ありがとうございました
フォートを理事をかける
飛べてくるんだと言うのさ
使うといかねばならぬのだ
理事バッティングリッツ
ひもちゃかみちゃばじゃん仲間
勝負かけたら情けもよものがないうち
君はアゲマンの主席じゃないか
ノートワンガンつぼろうよ
使うと幸せつかもうぞ
スーパースタート
やるでやるまんまくところ
ご視聴ありがとうございました